I'm glad we coordinated today that we
both are white shirt this morning to all
the boys to PS I still love you official
sequel trailer numero dos I loved the
first one I was really surprised by how
much I loved that first one and I loved
PS I love you which is even better
raw so apparently the director from the
first one who is a female is not
returning for this sequel it is directed
by a male weird thing to do well culture
times if they ask my hired dudes anymore
but this guy was the cinematographer of
the first one and he was also the
cinematographer for all the haunting of
Hill House oh so it's gonna have a
little bit of a horror edge this time
around Lee lens itself you know what
else would have been a good idea
watching the first trailer nah no extra
footage let's go
[Music]
Peter and he won't even be from me
his didn't even know she existed recap
[Music]
good recasts cool actually it's like
that scene from frozen to sex
he's the head
this frame really well oh oh it's my
girlfriend's birthday I'm a jealous
[ __ ] now oh no this is bad
damnit Jacob just let Edward and Herbie
together yeah yeah he kind of looks like
Taylor Lautner to be a stretched-out
I've been trying to figure out what to
do for my girlfriend's birthday cuz her
birthday is two days before a
Valentine's Day so it always has to be
an event now I know we're doing I want
to just watch another Netflix movie at
home babe wanna watch a movie about a
relationship in parallel room accidental
love triangle she's put me in the
situation one too many times calling me
by other names John Andrew Gordon Kyle I
Lerman dead meet Jamie I wrote raka son
you know I actually really like this
setup idea because this is kind of a
more realistic version of what would go
on with a couple of people in high
school I mean I've met those people who
are high school sweethearts they got
married and they lived happily ever
after I mean the relationships always
take a lot of work but the idea of
focusing more on that love is more than
a feeling that's a lot of action it
takes a lot of work I think is something
that's interesting to explore for a
sequel because I thought that the first
one was just a row it was cliche sure
but it was a really well executed
rom-com so the idea of doing a sicko I'm
like what the hell they do for this and
that's on IMDB that they're already in
post-production I'm part three what
holds the frames it's a book series they
didn't know about me I wait for the
spin-offs to happen I think there's
actually a good message to take away
from something like this especially if
she ends up with the other or hey maybe
this is gonna end it in a polyamorous
situation maybe this is gonna be a
really really woke now okay yeah I just
like the both even if you two are
getting along as we see in that one shot
of the trailer were there you know like
doing the bro-hug like him it could be a
perfect love triangle I don't remember
the first one well enough to remember
whatever who this character is that's
coming back into her life but also the
consequences of those letters going out
I think it's all they have that come
back this feels like a other endless
sequels out of
surprisingly this feels like a natural
sequel look for some reason I thought
this would just be like forced and well
from what we're getting so far it's fun
that you're gonna see the relationship
evolve notice Antonio and Lana Condor
it's funny because I was watching
marriage story just yesterday and I was
like yeah that guy from girls mmm is the
breakout star and the guy from - all the
boys I've loved before is the breakout
star the movie and when a lot of condors
is an amazing actress and I got to say
to like even though they switched
directors granted it's just the trailer
it still feels like the energy and the
vibe the flare is all still there
sometimes that new things were like we
got the editor from the previous one to
direct this but I think transitioning
the cinematographer to directing this
there's a fairly good step especially
cuz they know they're the ones working
behind the camera working to the closest
with the director in terms of framing
and all that I have faith that this will
actually probably be probably a good one
and then eventually this can become like
Saul were like yeah everybody who's
worked on the previous films is gonna
get a chance to direct one at some point
you know pretty sure he's directing the
third one - wow she's conniving eights
of all the boys I've loved and the guy
playing John Jordan Fischer he's done a
lot of work in television pretty sure
he's like famous so I'm sure the primary
female demographic is very much excited
that he is in this movie very aware of
who he is yeah and I think it's
interesting this film will be dealing a
lot more with the jealousy theme that
occurs as you encounter a young
relationship that's usually what happens
and what happens after happily ever
anything yeah
because they even had that moment in the
beginning Noah was at the locker room
and girls were still sending him a bunch
of stuff even though he's taken and all
that my heart it was taken even though
his uh he's in a relationship you know
you still have to deal with the fact
that like some people are gonna be
attracted to your significant other and
are gonna try to pursue them so it seems
like both of the characters are dealing
with that but with Noah's character it's
more physical and then with Alana's
character looks like there's a motional
risk and I think on in
speaking in averages guys can get more
jealous of physical attachment and
girls can get more jealous of emotional
attachment I'm not saying like that for
all got it for size blanket statement
yeah you know what I think every act
John's right 100 percent I think this is
a mature step I'm excited to see what
they got in store when talking about the
the cinematographer from haunting of
Hill House taking this over I mean she's
like looking at a lot of the shots and
colors like I was starting to get the
vibes just in the visual language that I
would get in non scary scenes from
Animal House because there is a lot of
like blue and green and and like wood
based like settings and stuff that just
took me back there
well a lot of it felt like atmospheric
lighting of whatever the the lamps were
now looking like a natural illumination
from what the light is in there yeah
anyway guys are you excited for this are
you rooting she ends up with John and
the end teams on our team Peter which
one are you with comment below hey
subscribe
yay click that notification Bell yay
like this video yay then you guys can
check us out on her patreon page or we
do weekly q and A's TV show reaction
stream along several have reaction
highlights included and he does music
video reactions weekly hey patron of the
day
shout out to Jay Stewart if there's any
man any boy at our patreon that I send
letters to all the time while patreon
messages see you buddy
you are the boy I've loved till this
very moment oh man there's no before
here no only NASA's forever you and I
look at me Jake look at me
I want to you like an animal
my cup layer kangaroo oh I want to kick
you oh yeah they get almost kinky yeah
kick you hard a little hard kicking
slapping around a little bit you know
kangaroos don't slap they can punch
yeah they punch punch in case kangaroos
are men tail whip you I mean they are
manly tail whip I don't have a tail
well you could just do it from the front
you know we should rehearse the shout
outs now we shouldn't
you